so a quick addendum to the video that I
made that was addressed to OT and that
was talking about ads running on
creators channels and talking about what
creators can do about it more than a few
people ask in the comments is there
anything that viewers can do to control
the ads that they are seeing the short
answer not really it used to be that you
could tap on either the info icon or
like the three vertical dots and get the
options don't show this ad that appears
to be a Vanishing feature I don't have
it anymore I don't know uh if it's
location locked it might be but many
increasing people are now instead seeing
why am I seeing this ad and it's just an
infographic with no option to do
anything there is an area where you can
do something but it's not a great choice
basically either you need to allow
yourself to see whatever ads are being
placed on the video by whoever feels
like putting it there which is what I
discussed in the longer video or you
give Google permission to give you
customized ads which means you are
giving them permission to monitor your
online activity and then feed you ads
based off that so either you're seeing
what we're seeing or you're getting your
data scraped by Google